- Unions seem to be
having a bit of a moment.
You may have heard about
the successes of organizers
at Amazon warehouses or
Starbucks coffee shops, places
that have historically been
very difficult to unionize.
President Joe Biden has
promised to be the most
pro-union president in
American history, and as
of this filming, the entertainment
industry is still hobbled
by a protracted strike by writers
and actors flexing their unionized muscle.
- In addition to this press,
or perhaps because of it
public attitudes towards
organized labor are higher
than they've been in almost 60 years.
71% of Americans now
approve of labor unions
up from a low of 48% in 2009.
- Wow.
So people really like unions
and they really want to be in them.
Are we seeing a return
to the union glory days of
the forties and fifties?
- Not really.
In fact, not at all.
Actual union membership as a percentage
of the workforce is at its
lowest level of all time.
Despite the good PR,
America has never been less
unionized than it is right now.
- Why is that?
Well, unlike many other
countries where unions
are historically accepted and normalized,
America has a long tradition
of putting organized labor
at the center of our political
battlefield, resulting
in a lot of complex and
sometimes confusing legislation.
- And beyond that, the
economic, technological
and even cultural changes
of the last several decades
have created a landscape
less hospitable to collective
bargaining than ever before.
Despite their current
popularity, the survival
of unions has yet to be negotiated.
(soft music)
- Unions date all the way
back to the 18th century.
When the Industrial Revolution
crammed large numbers
of workers into factories,
inadvertently giving
them the opportunity to
share their frustrations and interests.
They used two main tactics
to increase their pay
and improve working conditions:
Collective bargaining, by
which all members benefited
from the union's negotiations,
and strikes, which used work stoppages to
demonstrate the employer's
reliance on their workforce.
- Organized Labor's heyday
was in the 1940s and fifties.
Thanks, in part to governmental policies,
like the National Labor
Relations Act of 1935,
which made it easier
and safer to organize unions
without being spied on,
harassed or otherwise
punished by employers.
Before that, it was common
for employers to use threats,
intimidation, even violence
to keep their employees from organizing.
By the 1950s, about one in
three American workers belonged
to a union, which is
credited as a key factor
in that decade's relatively
low economic inequality.
- But even back then, some business
and political leaders were
working to weaken union's power.
The Taft Hartley Act passed in 1947
limited union's bargaining strategies,
like restricting certain kinds
of boycotts and made it
easier for employers to
use non-union labor known as
scabs to circumvent strikes.
Union leaders were also
required to sign affidavits
denouncing any communist sympathies.
And anti-union propaganda
exploited white Southerners fear
of desegregation to stymie the spread
of unions in the textile
industries of the south.
- The stagflation
of the 1970s severely damaged
organized labor's power
and public image.
Business leaders managed
to convince politicians
and even their employees
that unions were standing in
the way of economic recovery.
Then in 1981, when Ronald Reagan,
who had once been a union
leader himself, summarily fired
over 11,000 striking air
traffic control workers,
it was seen as a potentially
fatal blow to the labor movement.
If the American president
could take such an
unequivocal stance against
the rights of striking workers
without any negative feedback
from the voting public,
perhaps union's best days
were really behind them.
- It's difficult to quantify
union's effect on the economy
but there does seem to be
a remarkable correlation
between union membership
and low levels of income
and equality, and the decades
of peak union strength
were not exactly bad for business either.
Perhaps that's why in recent years
as inequality has reached
historic levels and a small number
of corporations dominate
so much of our daily lives,
there's been a renewed interest
in unions as a potential counterbalance.
- But the American economy and
the world are very different
than they were 60 years ago.
For one thing, globalization has taken one
of organized labor's primary
tactics off the table.
If a factory owner doesn't want to give
into his striking workers' demands,
he can just move the factory overseas
to a country where
unions aren't a problem.
America has lost a ton of
manufacturing jobs as a result
and the ones that are
left are less secure.
- American labor law is
also much less hospitable
to unions than in other
industrialized nations.
Right to work laws
passed in 28 states allow employees to opt
out of paying union dues
even if they benefit
from the higher pay the
union negotiated for them
which has crippled many
union's ability to operate.
- And unlike in other countries
where organizers can negotiate
on behalf of all the
workers in an entire company
or even an entire industry, labor leaders
in America must organize
each individual workplace.
Starbucks by Starbucks,
Amazon warehouse by Amazon Warehouse.
Each one of these campaigns is
expensive and time consuming
for already underpaid
employees, and they face armies
of high price lawyers
and consultants hired
by the company to stop them at all costs.
- There's another cultural trend working
against labor organizing: loneliness.
In his book Bowling Alone,
the political scientist
Robert Putnam, chronicled how
Americans are becoming more
isolated, more suspicious
and less likely to
participate in social groups
like churches, bowling
leagues, and yes, unions.
- Forming a union is a
daunting and scary challenge
which requires strong bonds
of trust and solidarity,
what social scientists
refer to as social capital.
This was easier when hundreds
of people worked side by
side in big factories.
But today, even if our
employer is a giant corporation
we're more likely to work
in a small atomized
environment or even from home.
Turnover is much more frequent.
How can you convince
someone to help unionize
a place they don't expect
to be at very long?
And we're more likely to
spend our lunch breaks staring
at screens rather than
chatting with coworkers.
- And yet, despite all these obstacles
the will to unionize is alive and kicking.
According to the National
Labor Relations Board
there was a 53% increase
of union petitions filed
in 2022 and strikes were up
52% from the previous year.
Activists are fighting to pass the
Protecting the Right to Organize Act
which would restrict some
of the tactics employers use
to thwart unionizing efforts.
But with such a divided Congress
its chances are hazy at best.
- As the economist Suresh Naidu writes,
between the employer side
advantages given by US labor law
and diminished workplace social capital
it is difficult to see a
path to a persistent increase
in union density that is not concomitant
with a rewiring of workplace networks
and a transformation
of American labor law.
- Seems tough, but the silver lining is
that any such transformation would start
with a rise in public support.
- Which is exactly what we're seeing now.
- [Both] And that's our 2 cents.
- [Katie] Thanks to our patrons
for keeping Two Cents financially healthy.
Click the link in the description
to become a Two Cents patron.
(upbeat music)
- For more on leveraging your worker power
check out our episode,
How to Ask for a Raise.